ils sont finalement libérés par la
police Joshua retourne alors dans son
studio pour s'adresser à celui qui l'a
piégé
en février dernier à Paris ce jeune
homme avec une bien étrange aventure
c'est un joueur de jeux vidéo
professionnel ce soir-là il participe à
une session en ligne tout en se filmant
avec sa webcam
[Musique]
pendant sa partie il communique avec les
autres joueurs
soudain la réalité fait irruption dans
le jeu
la porte de son domicile vient d'être
enfoncée des hommes débarquent chez lui
ce sont bien des policiers ils
interviennent sans ménagement
pour savoir pourquoi on se fait arrêter
en bruit de fond sa femme en pleurs
[Musique]
la webcam continue de filmer
en fait les policiers ont reçu un appel
téléphonique leur disant que cet homme
venait de tuer sa femme il n'a
évidemment rien fait il s'agit d'une
très mauvaise blague
est-ce que je peux au moins couper le
truc parce que là les gens ils nous
voient en fait
ce qu'il a subi ça s'appelle un swatting
du nom du SWAT les unités d'élite de la
police américaine
l'équivalent du raid ou du GIGN ce
phénomène récent est né outre-Atlantique
dans le milieu des joueurs de jeux vidéo
[Musique]
ce qu'on appelle les gamers le principe
du canular envoyer la police chez
quelqu'un en prétextant un scénario
catastrophe
et le swatting vient donc de débarquer
en France
nous sommes en banlieue parisienne
Aymeric est le premier gamer français
victime du swatting c'était le soir de
Noël dernier près de Paris les policiers
sont arrivés avec les pompiers pour une
alerte au gaz
là grande échelle ce qui est pas rien
quoi donc et puis une alerte au gaz
c'est quasiment le pire qu'on puisse
avoir puisque du coup les pompiers
rappellent pas au domicile parce que
c'est dangereux par rapport à une fuite
de gaz et donc du coup ils sont obligés
de venir directement sur place quoi
Aymeric gagne sa vie en jouant aux jeux
vidéo en animé des sessions de jeux
payantes il est connu dans le milieu en
France et des milliers de fans suivent
ces parties en direct
son pseudo de joueurs et Pierre le soir
ou les pompiers ont débarqué il jouait
en ligne en stream dans le jargon des
joueurs
le délire à chaque fois du swatting
c'est de le faire pendant qu'on est en
train de streamer pour déranger le
streamer d'une certaine façon et que
tout le monde le voit en direct une
forme de vengeance entre joueurs avec
aussi de la jalousie vis-à-vis de ces
gamers populaires il a mené sa propre
enquête pour retrouver ceux qui l'ont
piégé en faisant la même chose que en
piratant leurs ordinateurs
c'était une bande d'ados qui a mené une
opération punitive contre lui
ils l'ont appelé op à hippier opération
spéciale enfin les gars étaient vraiment
à fond à fond dedans quoi et Pierre a
réussi à avoir accès à leur conversation
sur internet il nous lie les messages
que les auteurs du canular s'envoyés
pendant qu'il préparait leur mauvais
coup voilà j'ai son adresse et son tel
donc même dans le vocabulaire c'est
assez violent brise ce genre de fils de
[__] de youtubeur et là on arrive
on va appeler les pompiers
les auteurs auraient entre 13 et 17 ans
selon et Pierre il apportait plainte à
faire en cours
[Musique]
l'arrivée du swatting en France a fait
réagir la petite communauté des joueurs
nous sommes à Paris à la rédaction de
Gameblog un site spécialisé dans les
jeux vidéo
donc on parle de ff15
tous ici sont joueurs et journalistes
comme Carole blogueuse et animatrice de
jeux vidéo en direct ces cas de swatting
ne la surprennent pas elle est de plus
en plus confrontée à la violence des
joueurs pendant ces séances en ligne
c'est quand même un petit peu un petit
peu angoissant tout ça nous on voit
toute la haine qui peut déferler envers
nous envers les journalistes envers les
youtubeurs les les voilà les streamers
et finalement on est des proies on est
des cibles donc on a plus le droit de
faire ce métier on a plus le droit de
battre quelqu'un à un jeu vidéo s'il est
pas content s'il est en colère il va
nous envoyer les forces de l'ordre bon
c'est quand même un petit peu limite
c'est obligé c'est un clin d'œil depuis
l'affaire et Pierre les cas de swatting
se sont multipliés en France et pas
seulement contre les joueurs de jeux
vidéo des anonymes des politiques des
people se sont fait piéger par de
simples coups de téléphone comme le 12
mars dernier en plein Paris cette fois
là c'est un animateur télé qui s'est
fait swatter un cas classique la police
accrue avoir affaire à un homme violent
qui aurait tué sa femme
sur Twitter le réseau favori des gamers
la police met en garde les squatteurs
appellent malveillant
# soiting hashtag canular c'est
comportements sont punis par la loi il
risque jusqu'à deux ans de prison et 30
000 euros d'amende
les autorités françaises prennent ça
très au sérieux l'officier de police
Christophe Crépin dénonce le
comportement irresponsable des
squatteurs ce genre d'individus qui font
des blagues c'est pas des blagues
potaches des blagues qui peuvent avoir
des répercussions c'est des blagues qui
utilisent des effectifs de police qui
peuvent être employés sur d'autres
missions surtout en ces périodes
terroristes et je demande à ce que la
justice passe et qu'elle passe avec la
plus grande sécurité à l'égard de ces
individus
les policiers français ne veulent pas
d'un scénario à l'américaine les
États-Unis sont confrontés aux swatting
depuis une dizaine d'années et là-bas ça
donne ça
il y a 400 interventions pour rien
chaque année des interventions toujours
très musclées
nous nous rendons à Bradenton en Floride
pour suivre un entraînement de cette
police d'élite
c'est la joncode qui nous sert de guide
je vous emmène à notre camp
personne ne vit dans le coin c'est mieux
pour pouvoir s'exercer au tir
Tod fait partie du SWAT depuis 4 ans
aujourd'hui séance de tir rapprochée
interviennent environ 40 fois par an
chaque opération coûte 10 000 dollars
qu'il s'agisse d'une vraie affaire ou
d'une mauvaise blague
le soit des hommes sur entraînés sur
équipé rodé au pire situation sauf au
canular
c'est terrible car ça mobilise beaucoup
d'officiers de police
on nous appelle pour des interventions
lourdes souvent pour des personnes
armées alors on s'attend toujours au
pire et puis finalement arrivé sur place
on se rend compte que ce n'est rien on
met en œuvre beaucoup de moyens pour ça
et moi ça ne me plaît pas du tout
leurs interventions sont toujours
violentes pour eux chacun est réel nous
nous rendons au nord du pays dans une
petite ville du Minnesota c'est là qu'en
pleine nuit Joshua et sa famille ont eu
la peur de leur vie en voyant débarquer
le SWAT en février dernier Joshua est un
gamer lui aussi
voici mon studio en vrai pro il a
aménagé cette pièce au sous-sol de la
maison de ses parents pour ces parties
de jeux en ligne
j'ai besoin d'avoir ces trois écrans
devant moi car pendant mes directs il se
passe beaucoup de choses le jeu les gens
qui commentent
80 000 personnes le suit sur internet de
quoi susciter pas mal de jalousie
je suis à ce film quand il joue cette
fameuse nuit quelqu'un appelle la police
en se faisant passer pour lui
à la police que quelqu'un était sur le
point de me tirer dessus et tout d'un
coup ils ont entendu un coup de feu et
puis plus rien un long silence comme si
la personne au téléphone c'est-à-dire
moi venait juste d'être tué
la police envoie immédiatement le soit
au domicile de Joshua il nous montre la
vidéo enregistrée par sa webcam cette
nuit là
là il est à peu près 1h30 du matin je
suis en train de jouer comme tous les
autres soirs en prenant mon pied
super relax
et là je retire mon casque car j'ai
entendu un bruit
ça c'est ma mère qui frappe à la porte
c'est DJ elle me dit il y a la police
est-ce que tu sais de quoi il s'agit
il quitte brusquement la partie et
rejoint ses parents à l'étage
les policiers pointaient leurs armes sur
nous à travers la vitre
et nous on essayait de les faire rentrer
le plus calmement possible mais en même
temps il nous criaient de garder les
mains en l'air finalement on a réussi à
ouvrir la porte et ils se sont rués sur
nous
ils ont plaqué mon père au sol comme ça
ma mère était là elle a dit il y a des
enfants dans la maison qu'est-ce qui se
passe
puis ils l'ont plaqué par terre elle
aussi comme ça
ce qui a le plus traumatisé Joshua cette
nuit là ce sont les armes pointées sur
son petit frère de 10 ans à ce moment-là
pour les policiers tout le monde est une
menace potentielle même les enfants
j'avais peur que quelqu'un ne soit
blessé
ou qu'il se fasse tirer dessus et qu'il
meurt
ils sont finalement libérés par la
police Joshua retourne alors dans son
studio pour s'adresser à celui qui l'a
piégé sa webcam tombe toujours
[Musique]
je savais que les gens qui avaient fait
ça me regardaient en direct je suis sûr
qu'il ne savait pas que je vivais ici
avec ma famille je voulais leur faire
comprendre ça
leur faire comprendre que ce qu'ils ont
fait était vraiment dégueulasse
personne ne devrait vivre ça
je suis à crac et fond en larmes en
direct
[Musique]
retour à Bradenton en Floride une toute
petite ville mais qui a déjà subi
plusieurs swatting nous avons
rendez-vous au commissariat du coin
je vous emmène dans le bureau de
centralise tous les appels d'urgence de
la région et qui mobilise ensuite les
patrouilles sur le terrain
les vrais appels d'urgence comme les
canulars comment faire la différence
c'est pratiquement impossible
aujourd'hui c'est l'agent Franck qui est
de garde à lui de faire la part des
choses comme avec cet appel que se
passe-t-il
au bout de la ligne un enfant paniqué
apparemment
ok est-ce que quelqu'un est blessé
personne n'est blessé
ok est-ce que quelqu'un éternel est-ce
qu'il y a des armes dans la maison
il a essayé de vous poignarder où est le
couteau maintenant
alors
le père vient d'arracher le téléphone
des mains de l'enfant de quoi s'agit-il
c'est un problème de violence domestique
un père de famille a tenté de poignarder
son fils et le père a raccroché de force
on vient d'envoyer une patrouille pour
vérifier ce qui se passe
l'agent franc reste très calme c'est son
job cette fois là il ne s'agit pas d'un
faux appel mais il n'envoyait qu'une
simple patrouille une question
d'appréciation et d'expérience les
auteurs de canulars le savent bien alors
ils échafaudent de vrais scénarios pour
être certain que le soir va être
mobilisé
c'était la spécialité de matthewegman un
adolescent auteur de 26 dans l'espace de
5 ans nous nous sommes procurés
l'enregistrement d'un de ses appels à la
police ce jour-là il se fait passer pour
un preneur d'otage
il va même jusqu'à mimer la présence de
ces supposés victimes
à avoir été arrêté il purge une peine de
11 ans de prison
dans la plupart des cas les auteurs des
canulars des génies de l'informatique
arrivent à masquer toutes leurs traces
les États-Unis comme la France restent
sous la menace de ses swatters qui ne
semblent pas mesurer la portée de leurs
actes
[Musique]